[Musique]
et alors la solution est bien la
solution ce serait probablement dentaire
une troisième phase après la soumission
et l'agression peut-être verra-t-on un
jour l'humanité entrer dans une
troisième phase que j'appellerais alors
résolument la réconciliation la
réconciliation de l'homme avec la nature
mais alors ceci pose des problèmes qui
sont plus simplement des problèmes
techniques des problèmes administratifs
des problèmes législatifs
cela pose des problèmes d'ordre mental
d'entre psychique est bien trop rude
entre morale est ce que l'homme voudra
acceptera de modifier sa philosophie de
modifier son attitude vis à vis du de la
nature et en particulier des autres
êtres vivants
acceptera-t-il de se considérer
désormais comme un des éléments de la
biosphère comme on dit maintenant un des
éléments de la nature vivante ou bien
est-ce qu'il continuera à se considérer
comme le propriétaire de tout ce qui est
à la surface du globe avec le droit de
vie et de mort d' abus éventuels sur les
ressources de la nature
[Musique]